what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to mob deep shook ones
part one official audio before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos okay
[Music]
the most violent of the valentine's
crimes we give life to if these
queensbridge kids don't like you we
bring drama the worst kind of enemies
your first time will be your last earth
memories it's only your own fault i gave
you fair warning beware
okay so he's letting you know
that he's he's threatening you right but
he's giving you a warning
so therefore he's a nice guy a killer
kids who don't care unaware of it in
time it ain't a mystery
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's saying there's a pie right
and i think the pie is like
the bread the money
the bag
all of the above but everybody wants the
pie and it's not today's thanksgiving so
you know
you might think we share the pie no
not
in shook ones
keep a positive mind and walk a straight
line don't worry
[Music]
so this dirt won't hurt if i listen to
the lessons and the rules i learned on
these streets for 19 years and not
leaving my first priority is to reach 21
breathing forever beef nobody will ever
be even so i grab the heat before
freezing lost in this foul my state i
can't keep straight thinking but i keep
my eyes on the earth without blinking
it's hard to be a man in this land of
the venom any man try to front he gets
slugs in him because
okay so he's saying that he's just
trying to make it to 21.
so he lives in a dangerous neighborhood
like not good
[Music]
straight up shook one shook
[Music]
a shook one so is he saying like
like he's scared like he's shook
[Music]
[ __ ] don't foreign i don't got time
for the heat shakes she say i'm bigger
than that claiming that you pack a cat
but you're scared to get locked once you
get up on the island change your ways to
stop 13 years into projects the hard
times are living wake up in the morning
thank god i'm still living sometimes i
wonder do i deserve to live
wow
do i deserve to live
oh that's
that's deep
[Music]
[Music]
you don't when i roll up don't be
complete because i'm creepin
don't be white cause i'm creepin don't
beat wait
it's like max ahead you're doomed when i
roll
[Music]
[Music]
and guns in numerous ways that we choose
to earn funds
some [ __ ] get shot locked down and
turned guns
okay that that so
i'm not gonna say it you already know
what but there they get shot
locked oh my god what did he say i
forget but that lyric reminded me of
it's like a cycle it's so interesting
not even interesting like it's sad
almost like it's almost notable in rap
music and like
like like it's a proud thing to be brave
like i think it's bravery right in their
eyes right it's brave to like be the guy
with the gun to not be afraid to shoot
someone to not be afraid to like do
whatever it takes to get the money but
half the time these rappers end up like
dead by 25
and i have no idea with this guy maybe
he lived a full life i don't know but
um
yeah it's it's like sad almost like
a lot of the guys i was like reacting to
when i first started on youtube like
king vaughn um there was another one the
other day
like they they literally die or go to
jail i don't know
but it's weird because if you get locked
up it's it almost seems like it's it's a
good thing like
like that means you're brave enough and
you're like hard enough to get locked up
[Music]
he's just
[Music]
oh okay so the phrase shook one refers
to someone who acts tough and hardcore
but when faced with murder and crime
they're scared and run away
i don't me
when there's murder or crime i will be
running i do not care what anyone says
my ass
ryan oh my god i'm a shook one then
um okay i honestly didn't really like
this song i was requested it by this big
youtuber um that has over a million
followers i was like what he found my
video
um
so i'm sorry man if you like this song
but
it's like i don't really like the 90s
beats to me i'm i'm 20 oh my gosh i just
turned 25. i'm 25
so
and i didn't really understand what
shook one meant so i think now that i
know what it means the song might have
made a lot more sense
is there anything else
okay i don't think so
but let me know in the comments if you
guys like this song and let me know if
you guys like my music reactions my red
pill reactions or if you just have clips
you want me to react to um it would be
very helpful
um i always if there's like clips that
people dm me on instagram uh my
instagram is just pearly things but with
a z at the end
um it's like very helpful so i'll talk
to you guys next time don't forget to
subscribe